Nos habéis mandado miles de mensajes pidiéndonos
que hablemos sobre las PROTESTAS de  NICARAGUA.
Las más violentas que ha sufrido este país en los últimos treinta años, donde varias personas ya
han perdido la vida.
Y sí, ya sé lo que me vais a decir: Fonseca,
llevamos casi un año pidiéndoos que habléis de Cataluña y seguimos esperando!!
Vale, tenéis razón…
y ese vídeo va a llegar pronto. Pero el caso
de Nicaragua es especialmente urgente
En este país, casi
todos los medios de comunicación están controlados por el presidente
presidente, Daniel Ortega, y su familia. Es
más, el gobierno ha censurado la retransmisión de las
protestas en ninguna televisión. En otras
palabras, que, prácticamente, el único medio
por el que los
Nicaragüenses pueden conocer lo que está
pasando en su propio país es este; youtube.
Y por eso, casi
todas las fuentes de información que hemos
usado para este vídeo vienen de las fotos
y documentos que nos
habéis enviado todos los amigos de VisualPolitik
que vivís en Nicaragua. Gracias por vuestra
ayuda. Y sin
más rodeos, vamos a contaros ¿Qué diablos
está ocurriendo en Nicaragua?
Hasta las pasadas semanas, Nicaragua estaba
considerado como el país más seguro de toda
Latinoamérica y,
a la vez, el segundo más pobre. Tal cual
como lo oís. Lo cierto es que Nicaragua es
un país lleno de
contradicciones. Su presidente, Daniel Ortega,
presume de sus raíces marxistas pero, a la
vez, se define
como católico practicante y, de hecho, ha
prohibido el aborto en su país. Sin embargo,
pese a tener unas
convicciones morales tan intachables, Daniel
Ortega tiene un juicio abierto por haber abusado
nada menos
que de su hijastra ¡Pero hay una cosa que
le tenemos que reconocer! Es un hombre auténticamente
familiar.
De hecho ¿Sabéis quien es la vicepresidente
de Nicaragua? ¡Exacto! Su mujer, que se llama
Rosario
Murillo.
En definitiva, que el presidente de Nicaragua
es todo un angelito. Sin embargo, lleva gobernando
el país
desde el año 2007 con un apoyo popular que
no baja del 60% ¡Pero no sólo eso! Si algo
le tenemos que
reconocer a Daniel Ortega son sus habilidades
diplomáticas.
Nicaragua es uno de los pocos países que
tiene buenas relaciones con Venezuela, Irán,
Rusia y a la vez, con Estados Unidos ¡Tal
cual como lo oís!
Muchos antiguos compañeros del partido de
Ortega, el Frente Sandinista, la acusan de
ser un vendido al
capitalismo. De hecho, aunque Nicaragua sea
un país tan pobre, es también uno de los
más estables de la
zona, con un crecimiento promedio de más
del 4.6%. Es más, la población bajo el umbral
de la pobreza se
recorta año tras año ¡No sólo eso! Mientras
otros países de la zona como México o Guatemala sufren un
auténtico éxodo de ciudadanos que se marchan
a Estados Unidos, los Nicaragüenses parecían
estar, más o
menos, satisfechos con su situación. Hasta
ahora.
La gota que ha colmado la paciencia de muchos
ciudadanos ha sido la reforma de las pensiones.
El gobierno
ha recortado las jubilaciones a la vez que
ha subido las cotizaciones a la seguridad
social. Como os
podéis imaginar, este movimiento no ha gustado,
ni a los empresarios ni a los trabajadores.
Y así es como
se han desatado las mayores protestas contra
el régimen de Daniel Ortega. Estas protestas
se han tratado
de reprimir con brutalidad policial y encarcelamientos
masivos. Ya hay 4 personas que han perdido
la vida
en los enfrentamientos. Incluso el gobierno
ha utilizado a sus propios simpatizantes como
fuerza de
choque para frenar a los manifestantes. Pero,
al menos por el momento, ninguna de estas
medidas ha
conseguido neutralizar los movimientos de
protesta.
Así que, ahora, la pregunta es ¿Por qué
está ocurriendo todo esto en ese momento
en el que Nicaragua no
tiene ninguna crisis económica? ¿Estamos
ante el fin del régimen de Ortega? ¿El fin
de la Nicaragua
sandinista? Hoy vamos a responder a todas
estas preguntas, pero antes vamos a ver un
poco de historia.
¡NICARAGUA SANDINISTA!
Los que veáis este vídeo desde España y
tengáis más de 30 años reconoceréis esta
canción al instante. Se
trata de Nicaragua Sandinista, uno de los
primeros éxitos de KORTATU. Lo cierto es
que, en los años 80,
Nicaragua se convirtió en todo un símbolo
de la lucha contra el Imperio Estadounidense.
Por aquellos
años, el frente Sandinista acababa de llegar
al poder tras décadas de dictadura de extrema
derecha. El
Frente Sandinista es un partido que se auto
define como marxista-leninista, antiyanki
pero que tiene algo
que os va a llamar la atención ¡Son extremadamente
religiosos! Durante esos años, muchos sectores
de la
Iglesia católica apoyaban sin lugar a dudas
a los Sandinistas. Sí, amigos de VisualPolitik,
estoy
hablando de la Teoría de la Liberación.
“Este es un mensaje de auténtico y verdadero
cristianismo”
Y sí, ese señor que veis en la pantalla
es Daniel Ortega. Por aquel entonces, Ortega
ya era el líder del
Frente Sandinista y el presidente del país.
Como os podéis imaginar, en mitad de la guerra
fría, Estados Unidos no estaba dispuesto
a que Nicaragua
se pasara al bando comunista. Así que el
por entonces presidente norteamericano, Ronald
Reagan, organizó
una de las operaciones políticas más polémicas
de la historia. Por un lado, se dedicó a
vender armas al
Gobierno de Irán, que estaba en guerra con
el Irak de Saddam Hussein. Todo esto, por
supuesto, en secreto
porque, oficialmente, Irán era un enemigo
declarado de EEUU. Después, utilizó todo
el dinero que ganó con
esta venta para financiar a la llamada CONTRA
Nicaragüense, que era un grupo de extrema
derecha que
luchaba contra el nuevo gobierno de Daniel
Ortega.
Estoy hablando de Nicaragua, un aliado soviético
en territorio americano que está a 2 horas
de vuelo de
nuestro país.
Por nuestra propia seguridad, Estados Unidos
no puede permitir que la Unión Soviética
tenga una punta de
lanza en Norteamérica.
Como os podéis imaginar, cuando todo esto
salió a la luz, corrieron ríos de tinta
¡Y de vinilo! Por eso,
si os gustan los grupos de música de los
años 80, encontraréis montones de referencias
a Nicaragua. Desde
este tema de Kortatu hasta el disco “Sandinista!”
de los Clash.
Y ahora os preguntaréis ¿Pero qué hizo
Daniel Ortega cuando llegó al gobierno? Pues,
en cierto modo,
podríamos decir que fue el precursor de la
Venezuela de Maduro.
Por hacer un resumen, el gobierno sandinista
se dedicó a nacionalizar todas las empresas
que estaban en
manos de los oligarcas locales y a financiar
todos los gastos pidiendo enormes deudas a
la Unión
Soviética y imprimiendo dinero como si no
existiera mañana ¿El resultado? En el año
1986, cuando la
revolución sandinista llevaba algo más de
un lustro en el poder, Nicaragua estaba sufriendo
una de las
hiperinflaciones más salvajes de la historia
mundial
En los peores momentos del conflicto entre
los líderes sandinistas y los rebeldes apoyados
por Estados
Unidos, todos los nicaragüenses tenían algo
en común: su dependencia en el dólares estadounidense.
Para que os hagáis una idea, los precios
en la divisa local, el CÓRDOBA, se duplicaban
cada 15 días. Esto
significa que si te tomabas una cerveza en
un bar y te costaba 10 córdobas, volvías
cuatro meses más
tarde y te costaba 3000 córdobas.
Os lo hemos dicho mil veces aquí, en VisualPolitik,
lo peor que le puede pasar a un gobierno es
tener
hiperinflación. Y por eso, pese a que Daniel
Ortega tenía un enorme apoyo social, incluyendo a muchos...
sectores de la Iglesia, los ciudadanos estaban
en una situación desesperada. Muchos pensaréis
¿Pero si la moneda local era tan débil? ¿Por qué no cambiaban dólares? Pues simple y llanamente,
porque cuando
vives en un país donde todo el mundo quiere
dólares, es difícil encontrarlos. Los que
veáis este vídeo
desde Venezuela o Argentina ya sabéis a lo
que me refiero.
Así que, en el año 1990, Nicaragua estrenaba
nueva divisa, el Córdoba de oro y un nuevo
gobierno
totalmente distinto.
Durante los años 90, Daniel Ortega estuvo
ocupando el banquillo de la oposición. Mientras
tanto, el país
conseguía recuperarse de la hiperinflación
y volver a esa situación de pobreza combinada
con cierta
estabilidad. Es decir, los nicaragüenses
seguían siendo pobres, pero al menos no perdían
poder
adquisitivo cada semana ni tenían que temer
por su vida.
Y con esta situación de relativa tranquilidad
llegamos al año 2006. Año en el que se vuelven
a celebrar
elecciones. Vamos a ver lo que pasó.
DE MARXISTA A ORTEGUISTA
Efectivamente, en el año 2006 Ortega vuelve
al gobierno. Pero esta vez se trataba de un
Daniel Ortega muy
distinto al que estábamos acostumbrados.
Por supuesto, seguía perteneciendo al Frente
Sandinista. Pero
tantos años en la oposición le habían cambiado
sus principios.
“Daniel Ortega a dejado de ser un partidario
del Marxismo-leninismo y ha pasado a ser un
partidario de
Daniel Ortega. Ese es el problema” –Declaraciones
de un militante del Frente Sandinista
Por supuesto que esta nueva versión de Daniel
Ortega mantiene un discurso socialista. Su
gobierno
garantiza acceso universal a la educación
y a la sanidad. De hecho, tanto la tasa de
escolarización como
la esperanza de vida han crecido en Nicaragua.
Pero esas ansias por nacionalizar todas las
empresas que
había en el país se han sustituido por un
discurso mucho más moderado.
“Los trabajadores de la ciudad y el campo,
obreros, campesinos… los productores, los
emprendedores, los
pequeños empresarios, los grandes empresarios…
todas las fuerzas sociales y económicas del
país ¡Todos
unidos!
¡Pero esperad un momento porque todavía
hay más! Hace 30 años, Nicaragua era el
país el enemigo perfecto
de EEUU. Pues bien, desde hace unos años,
Nicaragua ha firmado un pacto de libre comercio
con Estados
Unidos, el CAFTA, y colaboran en operaciones
contra el narcotráfico. Para que os hagáis
una idea, el
mercado de la agricultura en Estados Unidos
está hiper protegido. Pero el chocolate,
el café y los
plátanos nicaragüenses son la excepción.
Apenas tienen restricciones para entrar en
el mercado
estadounidense. ¡Pero la cosa no termina
aquí! ¿Recordáis las zonas económicas
especiales? Os hemos
hablado mil veces de ellas. Se trata de una
zona, dentro de un país en desarrollo, donde
hay pocos
impuestos y leyes más flexibles que permiten
atraer a las empresas extranjeras. Pues bien…
¡Nicaragua
también se ha puesto las pilas en este respecto!
Esto que estáis viendo es un anuncio del
Gobierno de
Nicaragua para atraer a los inversores internacionales.
“Si alguien está pensando en invertir en
Nicaragua, le animaría a venir y hacerlo.
Tendrá las mismas
ventajas que encontraría en muchos otros
lugares cercanos a EEUU, población bilingüe
y bien educada”
Por sorprendente que parezca, desde que Ortega
volvió al poder, Nicaragua se ha llenado
de call centers
de empresas de todo el mundo. Mano de obra
barata, impuestos especiales y lo más importante,
es el único
país de la zona sin guerrillas urbanas ni
violencia en las calles.
Y os preguntaréis ¿Qué le ha pasado a Daniel
Ortega? ¿Ha tenido una revelación? ¡Por
supuesto que no! Lo
que pasa es que se ha dado cuenta de que es
más fácil mantenerse en el poder cuando
la economía va,
razonablemente bien. Prueba de ello es que
elección tras elección, Ortega gana con
porcentajes superiores
al 60%. Por supuesto que hay toda clase de
fraudes electorales. Sin embargo, habría
que ser muy tonto
para pensar que Ortega no tiene apoyo popular
¡Pero no sólo eso! Ha descubierto que si
las finanzas de un
país va bien y tu controlas el país con
mano de hierro, tus finanzas personales también
van muy bien.
El presidente Daniel Ortega ha nombrado a
su esposa e hijos en cargos claves del Estado,
mientras la
familia amasó una fortuna gracias al petróleo
de Venezuela
Mientras tanto, su gobierno ha invertido buena
parte de ese dinero en evitar que nadie le
haga sombra.
Prácticamente todos los medios de comunicación
en Nicaragua son propiedad del gobierno o
de algún
familiar de Daniel Ortega. Y la nueva ley
de redes sociales, que se ha empezado a debatir
en el
parlamento en marzo de 2018, sería un intento
de crear mecanismos legales para censurar
y perseguir a
activistas opositores en redes sociales.
Sin embargo, las protestas han empezado por
una razón totalmente distinta. Ahora mismo
lo vamos a ver.
¿POR QUÉ PROTESTAN EN NICARAGUA?
La sabiduría popular dice que las revoluciones
ocurren cuando un país está en crisis ¡Error!
¡Craso
error! En realidad las revoluciones ocurren
cuando un país estaba pasando por un mal
momento y está
empezando a crecer ¿Por qué? Porque cuando
si no hay nadie a tu alrededor que conduzca
un BMW, no hay
BMWs que envidiar ¿Me entendéis bien? Pues
bien… de repente los Nicaragüenses están
viendo como una nueva
élite, surgida alrededor de Daniel Correa,
se está haciendo rica. Sí, claro, todo el
país está creciendo
económicamente. Pero… algunos están creciendo
más rápido que otros. Y habría que ser
muy tonto para
pensar que esta nueva clase alta nicaraguense
ha llegado a donde está por méritos propios…
Todo esto es lo que llamamos un “MOMENTO
POPULISTA”. Una ventana de oportunidad para
que pueda darse un
cambio de gobierno. Es como llenar una habitación
de gas. Sólo falta que alguien encienda un
mechero para
que todo explote. Y ese chispazo ha sido esto.
La polémica ley del INSS ya es ley en la
República
En resumen, el gobierno ha decidido bajar
las pensiones y subir las cotizaciones. Empresarios,
trabajadores y estudiantes han salido a la
calle como si llevaran años esperándolo.
Miles de personas
están en la calle. Y el gobierno se ve completamente
superado por la situación. Prueba de ello
es que han
obligado a las televisiones nicaragüenses
a que dejen de retransmitir las protestas.
Sin embargo, hay protestas por todo Nicaragua.
No sólo en Managua, la capital, sino también
en las
ciudades de alrededor e incluso en los pequeños
municipios. Muchos nos habéis escrito desde
la
Universidad Central de Nicaragua, donde hay
miles de estudiantes que llevan días concentrados
en
barricadas. Por lo que nos contáis, muchos
simpatizantes se encargan de llevar comida
y botellas de agua
a los manifestantes… pero después la policía
incauta los víveres. Y, aunque no las vamos
a mostrar,
tenemos imágenes de gente gravemente herida
por los antidisturbios. Se trata de una auténtica
batalla
campal en lo que hasta hace poco era el país
más pacífico de Latino América.
Y la pregunta que os estaréis haciendo es
¿Es este el fin del régimen de Daniel Ortega?
Como siempre os
decimos en VisualPolitik, en política y economía
no se pueden hacer predicciones. Que haya
mucha gente
protestando no significa que puedan cambiar
un gobierno. De entrada, todavía no sabemos
si todos los
manifestantes comparten alguna idea o algún
líder en común. Pero, en base a lo que nos
estáis contando,
diría que las barricadas se están llenando
con gente de todo tipo. Por un lado hay facciones
liberales
que exigen un cambio radical en la política
del país. Pero también hay muchos sandinistas
radicales que
se sienten traicionados por Daniel Ortega.
En fin, eso de las zonas económicas especiales
y la inversión
extranjera no suena muy marxista-leninista,
que digamos.
En otras palabras, que por el momento no hay
mucha organización ni, mucho menos, un líder
que aglutine
todo este descontento popular.
Sin eso, es muy difícil ser una alternativa
real al poder establecido.
Pero, esto no deja de ser mi análisis personal.
Y ahora, turno para vosotros ¿Qué creéis
que va a pasar?
¿De verdad creéis que Daniel Ortega tiene
los días contados… o nos queda Sandinismo
para rato? Podéis
dejarme vuestra respuesta en los comentarios.
Como siempre, no olvidéis que publicamos
vídeos nuevos todas las semanas así que
suscribíos a
VisualPolitik para no perderos ninguna de
nuestras actualizaciones. Si os ha gustado
este vídeo, dadle a
LIKE y compartidlo con vuestros amigos. Y
como siempre, un abrazo y hasta pronto.